say doc welcome back to thug notes this
week we working it with my sermon by
John Steinbeck this book tells the story
of two ranch hands a skinny Hood named
George and some gum be lookin mofo named
Lenny who be a bit goofy in the head now
I mean see even though Lenny's simple as
love to pet soft animals he too small to
handle them without busting them up so
as my boys rolling up to their new gig
George starts dropping some righteous
talk about how once they stack enough
dough they're gonna buy their own farm
and live the high life with no hassles
and big Lennie even gonna have his own
rabbits to tend to at the ranch George
and Lennie peeps some wrinkly old time
and then candy who've been working the
farm since forever I don't know where
the bossman son Curley steps to and
starts messing with Lennie for no reason
also turns out Curley just married some
hoochie who like the bustle with other
farmhands George tells Lennie he best
stay away from that trick when Lenny and
George start jabbering again about their
dreams of living like hi ballers candy
jumps in and say he can lend them some
scratch and live with him on that farm
with the promise of Candy's cash money
they realized they only got one more
month of hustling before they can start
living high off the hog lay the Curley's
wife peeps Lennie chilling all by his
lonesome
it stops teasing my boy after she asks
him if he want to touch her hair Lenny
gets aimed and start stroking too rough
this one she bout to squawk Lennie
tweets out and accidentally smash sir
neck woo man when he gets all scared
that George is gonna be mad and bails
when Carla finds his bitty lyin stiff he
rallies his posse to hunt Lennie down
but before the lynch mob can ghost
Lennie
George finds him chillin at a creek let
me ask George to talk about their dream
crib again to calm him down
that's George lemon lemme with those
sweet dreams of easy living he pulls out
a piece and puts a hot one riding
Lenny's dough
today
alright be you just think grasp in the
title of this book without checking this
poem by Robert Burns
the best-laid schemes of mice and men
gang got ugly and Leo's not but grief
and pain for promised joy just like
Bobby be doing in his poem Steinbeck
dropping some raw talk about how
although the American dream promising
the rights is like to hurry one who got
the juice to hustle it ain't nothing but
an illusion see up in this backward a
society sheisty rich folks stacking
branded the expense of the weak and Pope
who being robbed of their basic human
dignity so what started back preaching
up in here is that dreams that exist in
a culture of exploitation and he never
gonna be nothing but dreams so are we
supposed to be like them tired ass rich
folk who only look out for themselves
I'll should we help a brother out if you
keeping an allegorical up in here you
can say Steinbeck pulls in the same
question that came ax God in the story
of Cain and Abel am I my brother's
keeper
so let's get all biblical up in this
heezy and Genesis 4:12 God lays the hurt
on Cain by saying when thou tillest the
ground it shall not henceforth yield
unto thee her strength a fugitive and
vagabond shalt thou be in the earth
since Cain felt that kindred blood he
ain't never gonna enjoy the fruits of
his labor no matter how much he hustles
and since my boys tugging it up in a
world tainted by the curse of Cain that
farm lineand George always dreaming
about ain't never gonna happen cuz as my
boy Steinbeck suggesting by name and his
character George Milton paradise is lost
Playboy you can also say this book
critiquing judeo-christian morality
player see my boys Lenny and George
reppin two opposing aspects of humanity
Lenny be all the animal appetites that
peeps always trying to deny which is why
you always want to pet soft things
whereas my boy George representing the
voice of reason I try to control them
beastly desires that's why George always
telling Lenny what to do
when George pumps a hot one in Lenny
skull it's like he trying to destroy
man's animal impulses so to rub that
judeo-christian morality
my boy got Isis day one brother just
like hey yo thanks for showing all the
love keep it gangsta and tune in next
week Playboy
[Music]